all right turn into our next guest Ellen
Hildebrand she is known as the queen of
the summer novel and if anything that's
an understatement she's written 29 books
many transporting readers to the Sandy
Shores of Nantucket Island Massachusetts
it includes her best seller the perfect
couple which is being adapted into a
television series she's got a lot of
best sellers though her new novel is out
today it's called the five-star weekend
and it follows popular food blogger
Hollis Shaw as she hosts the weekend
with best friends from four different
phases of her life it's hildebrand's
second to last Beach novel before she
plans to retire this is not breaking
news Alan you have announced it before
uh but it is a very sad approaching date
for many readers or exciting if you're
me yeah
um you know but they have fortunately
they have a long back list that they can
make their way through absolutely
rereading uh does does reward itself all
right the five star weekend what we
didn't say in that little summary there
is it follows a widow uh who reconnects
with five friends how did this idea come
to you so I
have writer friend who
our weekend on
on she invited me for a drink and she
explained premise of it and although her
situation was different what I attached
to was the idea of inviting your closest
friend from each phase of your life
because as we get older our
circumstances change we grow and our
friendships change and what would it be
like to invite people from different
stages of your life would they get along
would there be drama because they don't
know each other because they don't know
each other so that's what the book
explores so not only that so uh Hollis
holla shows her name every time I read
your books I'm practically drooling on
the page because this is what she served
at dinner
cilantro and lime marinated Swordfish
with avocado sauces summer squash tart
with goat cheese and mint large green
salad homemade baguettes with black
pepper butter but of course can you
actually do you actually cook yourself
can you do this I do so I vacay
all the black pepper just put it in the
butter right well I turn my own butter
all right
that's Amish Vibes right there okay I
turned my own butter it's surprisingly
easy but yeah so I'm a food yes plays
such a major role in your books which I
love so much but I love the idea of this
five-star weekend bringing friends
together because one of the people quote
friend isn't really a friend it's not
somebody that she even knows but they do
have a connection that we find out later
right jaw dropping so the friend from
midlife that she invites is one of her
followers on her blog and she's never
met her before but they've sort of
connected in the messages and sometimes
people will do and yeah it turns out
there's a big surprise about who she is
I know reading is up to the person who
holds the book but what do you think
readers should take away from this I
mean I feel like it's a celebration of
women's friendship and an acknowledgment
of the fact that we do change and you
know if I had the five-star weekend you
know my friends from high school would
are very different from the friends I
have now of course and their only common
ground is me and so it's such an
interesting Dynamic yeah that's
fascinating and I didn't think who would
you invite when you think about your
life and how would they get along yeah
and I think guys can do it too of course
of course but you say that this is your
last book in the lead second to last
second to last second you're winding
down yeah why are you winding down do
you really feel ready well clearly you
feel ready why do you feel ready is a
better question I just want to make sure
that every book that I write is as good
as or better than the last one and I
feel myself coming to an end of my
natural material Nantucket is four miles
wide and 13 miles long you're running
out of ideas running out of material
yeah and I just want to make sure I go
out on a very high yeah yeah I I mean I
imagine okay but what if you move from
Nantucket to someplace else well it's
not impossible right never saying well
so then what are you going to do in
retirement given you're already churning
your own butter
[Laughter]
I started I'm starting a podcast
launches tomorrow
to my books the beach and Beyond with my
work husband Tim talks books and it's a
big swing literary podcast we have Ann
Patchett we have Colleen Hoover we have
Taylor Jenkins big guns we have Gilbert
Cruz who is the editor of the New York
Times book review did an interview so
I'm gonna that's where I'm starting to
focus my nrj but aren't you and your
daughter how old is your daughter she's
17. 17. aren't you and your daughter
doing something together yeah so we're
gonna write two novels set at a New
England boarding school and that will be
sort of a fresh arena for me with a new
gen Z voice sprinkled in so looking
forward to that and how are you feeling
Ella we always have dances thank you one
of the first times you came you were
going to have cancer surgery the very
next day yes you couldn't believe that
she was in the studio the day before you
were going yes surgery so ironically on
Sunday night I was at a book party and
my surgeon who did my double mastectomy
was at the party and I got to say thank
you to her in the last nine years since
I was first on I've written 15 books wow
and I got to see my children grow up
yeah and that is that's priceless what a
beautiful thing uh and you've given the
world another beautiful book when you
arrive on our set to do these interviews
I know my summer is on its way as well
when I see these images yep uh so well
done so well done Ellen Hildebrand thank
you very much the five-star weekend is a
five-star book and it's on sale right
now go get it now